dreaming of that California lifestyle
well you better be saving the reason our
poverty rate is high or the highest and
then the country is the cost of housing
the number of people in California who
can afford to buy a home continues to
fall the median home price in California
is 519 thousand dollars while the
national median is two hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars
between January 2012
and 2019 the average list price for
homebuyers rose about eighty-five
percent the median home price in the
United States only rose about 53 percent
in the same time frame today a mere 54
percent of Californians are homeowners
only New York State had a lower rate so
what's going on here California has been
a hot spot in the country's growing job
market between 2010 in 2018 more than
29,000 jobs were added each month that
adds up to around 3 million jobs in less
than a decade
meanwhile the pace of new housing
construction hasn't kept up between 2010
and 2017 California issued about six
hundred and thirty-five thousand new
housing permits and that's well under
the state's projected housing needs this
contrast is particularly stark in the
Bay Area where the average home value in
certain counties has surpassed 1 million
dollars all these high-income workers
now who want to own home but there's
just simply not enough housing out there
for them to buy and so unfortunately
what you've seen happen is that housing
has ended up going to the highest bidder
so why were so few homes being built in
California for starters it's not cheap
to build their homes in California's
coastal metros are three times more
expensive to build than in the rest of
the country the cost of labour land
material and government fees are all
very high in California California also
has more comprehensive building
standards which can add to costs and
bogged down the pace of new construction
according to a 2015 government report on
housing costs the state requires
builders to use high-quality building
materials so
windows insulation in heating and
cooling systems to achieve certain
energy efficiency goals
another factor limiting housing supply
local control over zoning a lot about
the realities local control of land is
in the sense the cornerstone of all land
use regulations these rules allow
residents to snub out new development
that might change their neighborhoods
that power can be used to cancel plans
for things like new apartment buildings
apartments can house more people in a
given amount of space which in turn can
increase strain on local roads or
schools so some homeowners in California
oppose their development this opposition
to increased population density can
limit new housing supply for middle and
lower income Californians and drive up
prices for existing homes there is also
a debate around the law that passed
decades before the latest housing boom
we have proven here in California that
we the people not the politicians are
staying with us in the late 1970s
California limited large increases in
property tax to 2% annually unless the
property is sold or renovated critics
say this tax law can influence local
governments who determine how available
land is used they argue officials give
preference to businesses over housing
developments because companies can
generate tax revenues beyond property
tax which could mean that this local tax
law limits supply
the global market is also playing a role
in California's housing loads Chinese
buyers are currently leading foreign
investments in the United States real
estate and nearly 40 percent of the
Chinese buying American real estate make
their purchase in California their bids
were often placed at the higher end of
the market which contributed to
accelerating market rates these foreign
investments spiked in the latter part of
2015 but have since declined while the
state analyzes its options California
sheds residents at ever increasing rates
net migration has been negative for the
last decade in the state and a big
reason why is that California with its
weather and opportunities is just too
expensive
[Music]